hier la france a profité de son premier
jour de liberté retrouvée après presque
deux mois de confinement imposé à paris
c'est au tour du canal saint martin dans
le 10e arrondissement de la capitale que
des centaines de jeunes ont décidé de
fêter ce déconfinement apéro à ciel
ouvert vers qui s'échangent regroupement
de plus de 10 personnes port du masque
quasi inexistant ces images semblent
provenir d'un autre temps
pourtant c'est bien hier dans l'après
midi que ces parisiens ont décidé de
profiter de leur première journée de d
confiné pour célébrer une attitude que
l'élu de l'arrondissement alexandre
accord de bach attendait c'est un lieu
qu'on avait identifiées à haut risque
pour l'aider confinement si des
policiers ont décidé de remonter le
canal munis de mégaphones pour demander
aux jeunes de porter des masques et de
maintenir leurs distances les consignes
ne semble pas avoir été respectée sur
internet les réactions ne se sont pas
fait attendre
je suis très en colère de voir qu'à
paris au canal saint martin les jeunes
parisiens ne porte pas de masque ne
respectent pas la distanciation ni le
regroupement à moins de 10 personnes il
se croit invincible
je refuserai d'être confiné à nouveau à
cause de ces idiots pour la maire du 10e
arrondissement il ne faut pas les blâmer
mais il est important de réagir je
comprends le besoin de liberté surtout
pour les plus jeunes j'en appelle à la
responsabilité et à la vigilance de tous
le temps des regroupements n'est pas
encore venu c'est important de respecter
les règles espérons que le message passe
tout cas ils ont fait une bonne voie à
la mer du 10 juin de regarder d'autres
contentant alors les séries fait-elle
déconfinement est ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre vous qu'il fait ou vous qui
fait pas jean michel maire qui kiffent
est ce un bien grand mot
moi je peux comprendre parce qu'on a été
les français ont beaucoup respecté le
confinement est au bout d'un moment la
cocotte-minute
on peut lui donner un peu d'oxygène
comme ça c'était le premier jour j pas
qu'il faut faire ça tous les jours
le premier jo et les gens ont voulu
fêter ça et puis je suis désolé ils sont
pas plus serré que dans le métro donc
voilà si mettre des masques et social
ouais c'est pas bien ça se travaille et
qu'il faut faire du shopping ou alors
métro on va pas faire du shopping à 8
heures du matin sa vie trop goudé le mec
tu le mets qu'il va prendre le métro à 8
heures du matin bondé pour aller faire
du shopping
donc tout le monde c'est vraiment le mec
qui la trouve très important à acheter
mais non c'est que le mec qui promet le
métro c'est ce qui n'est malheureusement
pas le choix et qui ont adhéré pas pour
aller travailler parce que le
télétravail était impossible pour eux là
en l'occurrence je comprend
effectivement ce que tu dis ça faisait
55 jours qu'on était confiné qu'on avait
envie de poudre de pouvoir sortir et
c'est donc je j'ai très envie de de leur
gueule et dessus mais en même temps je
les jeux je comprends ce besoin voilà
mais je voyais aussi quand ces images
ont été décryptés par des médecins ou
par des urgentistes ou par des gens qui
sont donc qui travaille à l'hôpital leur
leur mine déconfite se disant j + 7 ou
10 plus 15 qu'est ce qu'on va avoir nous
de rapidement sacrément goisses alors
voilà donc je ne vois pas ce qu'on aura
on sera dans cette tendance à dijon dans
quinze jours alors hier donc en fin
d'après midi
beaucoup de parisiens ont eu la même
idée se retrouver entre copains au bord
des quais sauf que très rapidement la
situation s'est envenimée
regardez ça a été chaud
tout à fait deux mois qu'on s'est pas vu
vraiment on a vraiment respecté on sait
pas du tout vu de sa forme de moi et tu
couvres aoc dit on voulait trouver un
endroit là où il n'y avait pas trop de
monde pour appeler ça un peu raté ça
fait plaisir de retrouver le monde qu'on
avait perdu pendant deux mois
tu es trop bien on a envie de faire la
bise et des cas leur nom peut pas mais
tout va on dit j'ai plein jour
alors forcément ces images ont provoqué
un tollé 1 et donc la police est
intervenue peu après 19h regarder les
policiers étaient équipées de mégaphones
pour dissiper la foule regarde cet art
19 heures plusieurs dizaines de
parisiens pas de masque souvent une
bière à la main la scène est interrompu
un peu avant 20 heures lorsque des
policiers à rift avec un mégaphone
vous êtes trop nombreux
merci de votre coopération les berges du
canal se vide petit à petit c'est la
déception pour louise et rebecca j'étais
content le jeune et j'avais l'impression
de profiter un peu de la vie normalement
mais en fait non pas à la demande du
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner la consommation d'alcool est
désormais interdite aux abords du canal
saint martin parce que vous êtes trop
nombreux a déjà passé une première fois
alors est ce que vous êtes choqués par
ces images vraiment moi je suis je
valérie gens me l'ont dit c'est vrai
t'as envie de ressortir tu as envie de
te dire on est on s'est tenus
tranquilles
grosso merdo pendant 55 jours on est
resté tranquille tu as envie de sortir
là on voit beaucoup de jeunes
on voit beaucoup d'insouciance parce que
c'est des jeunes insouciants mai mais
c'est catastrophique de ressortir comme
ça pourquoi la juve est vraiment ça me
prends moi je sors pas je viens juste
ici pour faire l'émission après je
rentre pourquoi parce que la france a
fait beaucoup d'efforts c'est vrai ils
ont merdé sur les masques ça j'ai déjà
dit les masques j'ai un problème avec ça
mais ils ont payé les gens quand même à
84% ils ont fait au mieux imaginer une
deuxième vague avec les urgences qui se
remettent encore en réanimation encore
en galère et prenez ce cas de figure
qu'un jour vous allez revoir votre
ministre ou votre président vous dire on
n'a plus les moyens de vous payer on va
vous payer à 30% ou à 50%
ça va être un drame il faut absolument
qu'il n'y ait pas de cette deuxième
vague faut absolument prendre en compte
que la france à un moment donné elle
veut elle pourra plus vous payez elle va
arrêter de vous payer une paix alors que
y aura des privilégiés et cette journée
plus les plus démunis et les plus
fragiles qui vont payer cette
insouciance de jeunes il faut absolument
qu'il ait pas de reconsidérer leur
confinement ça va être un drame
aujourd'hui à des gens qui ne savent pas
l'événementiel
les productions les les cafés les bars
les hôtels c'est un drame pour eux
imaginent et égoïstement mettez vous à
la place d'un mec qui au chômage qui
perd de l'oseille et qu'ils se démerdent
à faire des prêts qu'ils se démerdent à
faire bouffer sa famille et ils voient
ça il s'agit là là je suis pas prêt et
un jour est un jour la france dira c'est
50% en maintenant les salaires et les
gens là sa verdure à chaud et les gens
ont perdu des mois je t'ai laissé 25
nord à la raison kenny 25 morts après je
vous laisse tranquille 25 mille morts le
11 mai le 10 mai vingt-cinq mille morts
le 11 mai c'est bon on peut y aller
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne pas c'est pas en 24 heures on
rentable dans les doigts ya plus rien on
va se faire des galas j alors ils
rackettent les liens veille en aquitaine
est restée jean pierre pernaut regard
des cataclysmes à regarder mon tee
shirts pour habiller comme ça d'habitude
restez chez vous c'est fait par une
petite entreprise de loire-atlantique
j'ai eu envie de le mettre aujourd'hui
en voyant ces images qu'on a revu à
l'instant du canal saint-martin noire de
monde
l'épidémie n'a pas disparu au mas proche
des vingt-sept mille morts
quatrième ou cinquième pays le plus
touché de la planète c'est donc pas le
moment de faire n'importe quoi certes on
peut sortir pour aller travailler pour
faire ses courses le coiffeur hier pour
moi ou les remarquer en prenant toutes
les précautions d usage
voilà alors jean-pierre donc et la maire
de paris donc anne hidalgo elle a
dégainé très rapidement généralement
elle dégaine rapidement ou le savait
hélas c'était pour réagir hélas ne s'est
pas fait attendre puisque elle a demandé
la réouverture des parcs et jardins pour
éviter le problème a dit d'algues au
contenu des besoins des parisiens car
paris est une ville très dense je
renouvelle ma demande d'ouvrir à la
promenade les parcs et les jardins avec
port du masque obligatoire ce qui
devrait aussi le cas dans toutes les
rues de notre ville
alors elle a demandé ça elle s'est fait
rembarrer direct pas le pr par le
ministre de la santé
regardez qui a répondu à sa olivet
verrons apparemment il n'est pas comme
un fou sur khalid al pour avoir vu les
images auxquelles nous faisait allusion
hier sur les quais de seine de la
volonté
encore une fois on peut comprendre le
réflexe mais attention ça peut être
dangereux
non nous n'offrirons pas les parcs et
jardins à paris en ile de france ainsi
que dans les autres régions qui sont
classées rouge parce que non parce qu'on
n'a pas envie que les gens puissent
sortir prendre l'air mais que ça peut
être extrêmement tentant par le soleil
que nous avons aujourd'hui que les gens
sur un groupe trop ça mastro qui ne
respectent pas les groupes de dix et qui
ne reste plus pas respecté les
conditions des gestes-barrières qu'il a
rembarré anne hidalgo 1 le ministre de
la santé
à mon avis lui il a déjà pris une
contre-enquête des comptes 5 secondes
vous rendez compte commencer
insupportable ce parisianisme
à chaque fois on voit les parisiens qui
foutent le bordel rae qui te punit toute
la france entière ah ouais mais qu'il
chez lui dans le lubéron n'a rien fait
il est resté confiné 55 jours ils voient
les guignols sur quatre salariés je
crois encore 55 jours dans la tête c'est
insupportable c'est on dirait que c'est
paris qui commande pouvait rester condé
faut être les jours mais les gens
responsables
on était confiné le onze ont été
confinés les gens ils sortent voilà
c'est quand
histoire de parrot grèce il ya quand
même quelque chose qui n'est pas très
logique en interne ou en vendant parie
donc sur internet endroits mais les gens
sont plus serrés dans les endroits ils
peuvent aller est responsable tu laisse
de la place pour les gens sont dispersés
l'idée d'interdire les parcs et jardins
c'est justement pour que les gens ne
stagne pas s'il n'y a pas de lieu
monument park n'a pas de lieu d'endroits
où c'est agréable de se poser bien sûr
aussi regarder nous on a trouvé un truc
qu'on s'est posé à aller aussi et voilà
on s'est posés là on a fait chanter omet
s'est posée on a fermé nos gueules on
n'a rien demandé ni delgo regarder je
kiffe 12% bah voilà fait pas 90 à
rentrer venant de toute la france
et voilà l'art l'ensemble de la france
ne kiffe pas